les députés examinent aujourd'hui le
projet de loi de nicolas sarkozy sur la
délinquance un texte très contestée
considérée comme liberticide par
plusieurs associations et magistrats il
risque également les maires et mayer us
dont nicolas sarkozy veut étendre les
prérogatives
daniel sportiello jean christophe duclos
la philosophie de sa loi nicolas sarkozy
l'a résumé bien avant de la défendre
aujourd'hui à la tribune de l'assemblée
devant une gauche qui l'attend de pied
ferme
la sanction s'est dit in le premier
outil de la prévention
le texte déjà adopté en première lecture
au sénat prévoit en effet un
durcissement des sanctions contre les
mineurs récidivistes
parmi ces nouvelles mesures la
présentation immédiate en justice des
jeunes délinquants qui peuvent être
placés dans des centres éducatifs fermés
et en internat certaines peines seront
alourdies
ainsi le délit de rébellion passe de six
mois à un an de prison ferme
création également de nouveaux délits
tels le délit d' embuscade qui réprimera
les attaques et les guet-apens contre la
police les pompiers et les transports en
commun on voit très bien qu'à un moment
la chaîne pénale ne fonctionne pas et
donc il est nécessaire que
par ce texte nous passions comprendre
qu'on ne peut pas
commettre un délit est dépassé la ligne
blanche sans que ce soit sévèrement
sanctionnés la majorité se diviser sur
les peines plancher pour les
récidivistes
elles ont finalement été écarté lorsque
la peine maximale n'est pas attribuée
par le juge en cas de récidive ou de
réitération
à ce moment là le juge doit motiver
explicitement dans sa décision la raison
pour laquelle compte tenu de la
personnalité du délinquant il n'applique
pas cette décision
côté socialiste c'est la mobilisation
générale contre le projet et contre le
candidat probable de l'ump à la
présidentielle
c'est un show nicolas sarkozy en est je
dirais le principal metteur en scène
mais on ne peut plus se contenter de ça
je crois que s'il veut mettre ça à
l'assemblée nationale deux jours de
l'assemblée nationale c'est qu'ils
souhaitent une fois de plus faire ce
thème de l'insécurité un thème central
wars essentiel de l'élection
présidentielle même opposition des
communistes l'udf a déjà annoncé qu'elle
ne votera pas le texte de nicolas
sarkozy demain le débat promet d'être
chaud